why hello my fun youtuber viewers guess
I mean viewers number of yours I'm the
reviewer you guys the viewer that's how
you do this I need to practice how I
talk in the past you may have seen
Theory the film fan who has not retired
he used to do a segment called the fan
of the week in which he would pick out a
certain person who was involved with the
YouTube community in some way in regards
to movies like reviewing movie news
entertainment news something like that
and he would bring them out to his
viewers because he felt they were worthy
of use he thought that they were good
and he found that their videos were you
know like legit videos not just people
who are just you know said brother
camera like I'll tilt in like like hey
this is this movie is called Ides of
March and it's really good I mean it you
know like they actually try to make good
videos and I thought I'd do the same
thing on my channel and I'm gonna call
it stuckman suggests we'll see if that
sticks but my good buddy Kristian
harloff over the schmoes and though
introduced me to a channel called
breaking it down with Katherine Reitman
she's an actress in Hollywood but she is
really going forth with this YouTube
thing she actually started in January
the same month and around the exact same
time I started her videos are much
better in hide and seek in Spain I don't
even have to hide it in good lighting
good editing good writing good acting
just a lot of professional equipment and
things that are making her videos
considerably good but it's not just that
her personality her personality is
likable she's funny you can tell that
she's improving a lot of it's not all
just script and I really appreciate that
when you first go to her channel you it
looks it has the same color scheme as
mine red and black which is great it's
my favorite color combination
it all looks really nice and ee'aah you
click on her videos and you can tell she
has a lot of talent one of the things I
really like is the fact that I agree
with her a lot on her movie opinions
take Cowboys and Aliens for instance I
really like that film I had a lot of fun
with it
I'll have people complain about and I
didn't really understand why cuz I mean
you know you go into Cowboys and Aliens
what are you expecting it's called
Cowboys and Aliens it's called Cowboys
and Aliens I'll say it again check out
this clip of her review
good time watching I can watch Daniel
Craig do just about anything
tooth fairy inner-city basketball player
I can see it a sound guy you know I've
suggested a struggling single mom she's
got a discipline v she's got some
serious editing going on these reviews
were just great by the way but it's not
just that it's her personality that
shines through and that's why I'm going
to recommend her I'm not even gonna talk
about the Hollywood connections that she
has but I'm sure she's probably sick of
hearing that personality shines through
reviews even though they're very well
edited and I predict that in the future
she will have way more subscribers than
me I'd like to welcome her into the
YouTube movie reviewing community
because the schmoes have already
embraced her on their podcasts she's
going to be a guest host on there which
is really great so yeah if you guys
might check out her channel I would
definitely suggest doing that and
subscribing because like I said more
than likely she's gonna be the next
female Jeremy Jones I can't even imagine
that oh wow that was a really bad image
I just got in my head so stuckman
suggests I don't know about that title
but we'll see how it goes but yeah I
should just going over and subscribing
there and if you haven't subscribed me
yet I don't know how you watch the video
I don't even I don't even know that but
thank you for watching it I appreciate
that on Monday I'm gonna be seeing the
Big Ear with Jack Black which will be
wonderful and I'm sure and Tuesday is
the thing so look for those reviews